i came to get a general business  grounding and the core curriculum does  an  excellent job of that but what's  fantastic about our curriculum is we can  choose more than half of it  to really focus on what's important to  us as individuals and that's a really  special thing about the msx program  i've loved the academic experience here  so it's obvious we're coming to business  school we're going to be in class for  most of our time during the day and i've  i really just like the calibre  and the thought that goes into our  curriculum and one of the reasons i came  to the gsb was really to broaden my  business knowledge and  i feel that the gsb has really surpassed  that for me